greening europe pour la scène et europe
stable 0,11 soir l'europe car les super
eagles europe chrono en europe car
espère european and white europe mr bré
myeurop
[Musique]
bah
quoi qu'est ce que tu fais j'ai vu
c'était un clic je suis content tu
penses vraiment et je vous assure je
savais que c'est un classique le servage
ce texte inclut vous savez mais les
cheveux ils viennent d'où quand même
mathieu
je donne les salles de spectacle avant
que le spectacle commence c'est quand
même mieux quand vous êtes là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce que je ne comprends pas l'amérique
vous voyez vous j'en ai pour 5 dollars
quand avec leurs billets de un dollar
j'ai l'impression de laisser ma paye or
jeunesse que s'ils veulent mais ça fait
un peu mal psychologiquement il faudrait
revoir ça joe biden merci
[Musique]
vous vous trouvez dans une situation en
terrasse de café avec un café et un gros
bout de sucre mais que vous n'avez pas
envie de manger un gros bout de sucre
vous savez cette technique qui s'offre à
vous
et là du coup vous pouvez mettre votre
moitié de sucre dans votre café